(upbeat music)
(wooshes)
(sign squeaks)
- [Narrator] I was born in the 50s,
raised in the 50s and 60s in the Midwest.
I had a great and wonderful upbringing
by two great and wonderful parents.
Out of college, I went
to work for the military,
and spent almost 30 years
working for the government.
It was a great experience
and I'm now retired
and looking to try new things.
I try to take care of
mind, body, and spirit,
and I'm really proud that at
my age, I still feel great.
And I'm hoping to continue for many years
in the future.
I was always a little
bit inclined to think
outside the box and come
to my own conclusions
about life and what I
wanted and what I did.
One of which was, I've come
to enjoy a clothing free
lifestyle, back in the day
they called us nudists,
now they call us naturists,
but I just call it
natural and fun.
When I read the article in GQ
about Dr. Elist's procedure,
it really started me to thinking,
because a bigger penis had
been in the back of my mind
for some years, but I should emphasize
that going into the surgery, I did so not
because I felt I was small
or inadequate in any way,
it was just something that
I wanted to do for myself.
I guess you could call
it an act of vanity,
and I guess that's okay,
I think we're all entitled
to do things that make us
feel better about ourselves.
(upbeat music)
After the surgery, from
a lengthwise standpoint,
I think I gained about an inch and a half.
So a year later, soft, I'm
approximately seven inches long
and seven and a half inches in girth,
and believe me, that
size does draw attention.
As I understand it, the way
the implant will continue
to stretch the ligaments,
such that you can achieve
additional length increases
over a period of time,
however, I have to say,
if what I have now is
what I end up with, I couldn't be happier.
Now today I've participated
in clothing optional yoga,
I go to burning man events,
I'm a member of a nudist group,
and I participated recently
in the world naked bike ride,
and I had a lot of fun.
And I have to admit one of the big reasons
I had a lot of fun was
because a lot of heads
turned to look at me.
Whether we admit it or not,
we all enjoy being in the
spotlight, and thanks to
Dr. Elist the spotlight
comes on when my pants come down.
(upbeat music)
(wooshes)
(sign squeaks)